my name is Chris mauren I'm the
executive director of the Acton
Institute I have the privilege to be on
a committee with Anita and others to
help organize this event
so it's my pleasure to be here once
again
and thank you Anita for giving me this
two o'clock slot I know it's a
challenging slot
always a killer which is why we chose
our most scintillating topic for 2PM
financing cities
okay now unless you think of being
disingenuous
I'm actually quite serious whereas the
old adage goes all politics are local
and a focus on cities in a very real way
helps us to get to where the action is
now you don't live in a city in America
if you're not constantly bombarded by
requests for millages
usually for some service that you and I
mistakenly thought was already part of
the social contract
for example in my home city of Grand
Rapids Michigan and this past winter the
city let the rose disintegrate so badly
that
um
that you that they could and did swallow
whole cars and then the city demanded a
special 15-year millage to fix the
potholes
now like in Grand Rapids and I'm sure
this is your experience cities often
rely on a little trickery to get these
millages passed they hide them in
special elections when only their
pro-tax constituencies can turn out
but even more devilish in our case after
the millage passed of course it did it
was announced that the city needed to
borrow tens of millions of dollars
to fix the potholes through through Bond
issuance why because the millage
wouldn't start bringing money into the
coffers for a year and a half
so now I probably don't need to insult
your intelligence by stating how we got
to where we are Grand Rapids is not
alone many many many
localities
cities have precarious finances many are
on the brink of bankruptcy and as we'll
learn in this panel many are working
their way through bankruptcy
but let me tell you the hopeful and
truly exciting thing about the current
mess in City financing
like the alcoholic who has finally hit
rock bottom spend theft cities must
finally face up to their systemic
problems and Implement radical
fundamental changes
or if I might paraphrase my one of our
panelists Kevin our next speaker's book
for my optimism he said in regard to
cities and
in general along with the rest of the
economy the end is near and it's going
to be awesome
how going broke will leave America
richer happier and more secure
so from my perspective yes we are
entering into an era of interesting
public policy
competition at the city level and we're
going to see a lot of interesting things
happen
bad things of course but but also many
good things and I'm fully confident that
in the good things we will see the power
of good ideas free markets limited
government and Entrepreneurship carry
the day and they will not only create
prosperity for our local communities but
they will give us models and examples
for our state and federal governments
who surely need the same radical therapy
and therein lies my optimism and why I
think this panel is exciting so we're
going to start with our most radically
exciting participant today
Kevin Williamson he is National reviews
roving correspondent and the author of
several books I just mentioned one
when he's not sounding the alarm about
financial Armageddon he's also a theater
critic for the new Criterion
he's a journalist by background began
his career and worked for 15 years in
the newspaper business in Texas
Pennsylvania Colorado he served as the
editor-in-chief of three newspapers and
was the founding editor of
Philadelphia's Bulletin
you'll see him on Fox news CNBC MSNBC
and NPR
you might not see him there you might
just hear him NPR it's a lot of
imagination you can see him too his work
has appeared in dozens of Publications a
native of the Republic of Texas he now
lives in New York City please join me in
welcoming Kevin Williamson
[Applause]
you know in fact it's because you can't
see me on NPR that I suspect that's the
way I'm the one I'm most often invited
to
uh you know you were mentioning millage
and you know I was a newspaper editor
for a long time and I would interview
people for jobs just as long as they
didn't have journalism degrees because
people with journalism degrees don't use
the tend to make very good journalists
but um so I'm telling you I I don't want
to see your stupid college transcripts
because I don't really believe that
they're probably grading you according
to any standards and I just want you to
Define millage
and uh if they could Define millage they
got past the uh the first round
so yeah we're dealing with some uh
vastly complex uh highly technical
economic questions which is you know
when you're doing that everyone says my
God is there a theater critic in the
house and so
here I uh here I am share my expertise
uh because I'm precisely that kind of
nerd I'm a big fan of uh Chris Nolan's
uh Dark Knight Batman movies
and there's a wonderful scene uh the
late Heath Ledger as the Joker and he's
explaining to Batman his plan for
destroying Gotham which is not to use a
weapon of mass destruction or bomb but
to turn people against each other and to
reveal the average person as being as
twisted and sick as he is
and the great line with which he closes
is I'm not a monster I'm just ahead of
the Curve
and uh that's kind of how I feel about
Detroit
um
which I have come here to talk about
it is uh
oddly enough if you look at it
in terms of its deep politics it's deep
finances it's not really that unusual a
city it's not very different from
Cleveland or Philadelphia or Washington
DC it's just that its problem started
earlier than those cities did and it's
further along the path to
chaos than uh than some of those other
places are but I'm afraid and I
seriously believe that Detroit
is kind of what the future looks like
for a lot of these cities at least in
purely financial terms uh some of you
may remember a few years ago there was a
movie came out called Eight Mile uh
starring the rapper Eminem
and Eight Mile paints this very Bleak uh
picture of underclass life in and around
Detroit when the movie came out people
were complaining and there was this you
know the Chamber of Commerce
put out a statement or someone put out a
statement that you know makes Detroit
look so bad and uh you know as someone
from Detroit you should uh should have
known better than to portray the city
this way but in fact it's it's actually
quite a bit worse
uh which begins with the fact that that
movie never played in Detroit because
some years before that Detroit's last
movie theater had closed it's less First
Run movie theater uh it's the only city
of its size I think in the country that
doesn't have at least didn't have at
that point I'm not sure if one's open
since then although I can't imagine it
it would have
a first run movie theater if you look at
the retail environment the stuff that's
just not there uh you know normal stores
you'll find other places you know Home
Depots things like that it's just uh
Bleak uh one out of five
residency is gone
they're burned down fell down uh
abandoned vandalized Beyond habitation
they have 88 000 street lights that
don't work
that's most of the street lights in the
city so people talk about you know
internal flights when you're done
lions are here lights are sort of off
there
um but Detroit weirdly enough is kind of
a kind of a strong brand in some ways I
don't know there's a company called
Shinola that makes kind of high-end
watches uh they're a detroit-based
company and they advertise that fact and
they play up you know we're made in
Detroit and you know like we're tough
guy watches uh you know it's not jewelry
it's a it's a machine because it's from
Detroit
there's a fashion designer by the name
of John Barbados some of you may be
familiar with he's a Detroit native and
a couple of years ago he did a special
version of the Chrysler 300 automobile
uh you know he designed the interior and
was a special version of the car and
when they were rolling this car out uh
Chrysler unveil what was in its new
slogan it's new advertising slogan which
is imported from Detroit
and uh so you know they like to play
that up
John Barbados doesn't operate in Detroit
uh he's from Detroit uh he operates in
New York City in Las Vegas and lots of
other places he announced actually a few
days ago that after 15 years in the
business
he's thinking about opening a place in
Detroit
all right
the Chrysler 300 is made by Chrysler
which is not a company based in Detroit
it's an Italian company uh Chrysler is
owned by Fiat these days
and the 300 is built in Canada in uh
Ontario I believe at the Brompton works
so that's Detroit's big advertisement
for itself here's an Italian company
and a guy in New York selling you a
Canadian car
but we're going to pretend like it's
from Detroit because we all have this
emotional connection to Detroit as the
you know Motor City is the home of the
automotive industry
but the story of the automotive industry
in Detroit is actually a little
different from what most people think
1895 to 1900 was kind of the birth of
the the automotive industry in the
United States as a mass industry in
those five years there were 69 new
automobile companies started
not one of them was in Detroit uh they
were mostly in New England and Ohio and
a few other places
Detroit had a thriving economy long
before the automobile and the industries
associated with it wound up there in
fact that's why cars ended up being made
in Detroit because Detroit already had
all sorts of expertise from its other
Industries Marine engines were built
there so people who knew how to design
an engineer internal combustion engines
were mostly based in and around Detroit
The Carriage building industry was big
in Detroit so people who knew how to
build frames and be wheel rights and
those sorts of things were there so
Detroit wasn't built by the automotive
industry the automotive industry was
brought to Detroit by the fact that the
city already had a thriving industrial
engineering based economy long before
long before those companies ever showed
up and what's happened with Detroit
isn't really a
result of the decline of the automobile
industry
there are a couple of factors that have
led Detroit to its current
sorry state
uh one that some of the other guys here
we'll talk about in some more detail
than I will is just bad governance
especially profligate spending on
pensions
and the pension thing uh you know people
there's all sorts of technical stuff to
talk about with pensions and discount
rates and assumptions about this and
that but the main thing I think to
appreciate about the pension problems is
that the fundamental problem is
cowardice
so you have these public sector unions
you have politicians that want to pay
them more but they don't want to put it
on the budget they don't want to tax
people and take that money out and write
these people checks every month or every
two weeks for their salaries so they
promised them these great retirement
benefits and those of course you don't
have to pay for will eventually have to
pay for it but you don't have to pay for
them at the time of the promise it
doesn't show up on your budget every
year you have to go through this kind of
Kabuki thing of pretending like you're
paying for them and some states have
been better and cities have been better
and some have been worse oddly enough
New York where I live
which is generally one of the worst
governed places on Earth
has done a reasonably good job of
setting aside what it's supposed to for
its pensions I think they're technically
at 88 something like that
Illinois is like around nine
uh
and that's sort of optimistic
well because it's based on we're going
to make six percent for the next 30
Years really when are you invested in
buddy
um the other problem that Detroit has in
a degree that's probably more severe
than in a lot of other cities is the
problem of racial politics
and um
in Detroit this goes back much further
than it does in most places you talk
about Newark and Philadelphia and Los
Angeles having race riots the 1960s
Detroit was having him in the 1940s
Detroit is the only city in the United
States to have been occupied by federal
troops on three separate occasions
they almost all had to do with racial
violence
and part of this goes to something
that's not often talked about in
American politics which is the racial
aspect of the new deal and of
progressivism in general
and part of it goes back to the fact
that FDR was kind of not really good as
an administrator most people don't
really appreciate this about him because
you know we did win the war so give them
some credit
uh 1943 is kind of the ER episode in uh
Detroit's
history of racial problems so
you have a lot of black workers moving
into Detroit they're going to work in
the War Industries uh things are kind of
cranking up and this is not
received with universal welcoming
the times being what they were and the
Roosevelt administration gets it into
its head that they need to build some
public housing for all the black workers
who are coming into Detroit which was
probably not a bad idea because they
couldn't get housing through normal
channels uh there weren't really places
for them to live
and so they announced this big housing
project and they named it after
Sojourner Truth uh you know symbolic
and then they changed their mind
there was a local representative in
Detroit Catholic Democrat by the name of
tenerowitz
and because the Sojourner Truth projects
were going up and what had been a Polish
neighborhood
there are just you know the protests
there are cross burnings there are all
these sorts of things and so the
Roosevelt administration even though
people have already started moving in
put down deposits things like that flips
and decides this is going to be an
all-white housing project instead of an
African-American housing project
uh there was a civil rights leader at
the time named Charles Hill the Reverend
Charles Hill
who very rightly observed apparently Mr
Roosevelt thinks that says Journal truth
was a Polish lady
uh
but uh violence breaks out and it gets
pretty nasty at the same time Packard
decides to hire three African-American
workers
on one of its uh assembly lines in
response to the hiring of these three
African-American workers 25
unionized Auto Workers walk off the job
uh violence breaks out left and right we
have to send 6 000 troops in
to quell the violence in Detroit
at the time had a Republican mayor a guy
named Jeffries who was actually pretty
solid on some of the Civil Rights stuff
he was the one who had pressed for the
uh for the project to be built there in
the first place but because he was a
republican FDR didn't really respond
very quickly when the violence uh
started in fact it wasn't until the
Germans started using Clips in their
propaganda videos during the war that
the US government actually got up and
reacted
so you know white people writ large I
think and conservatives especially
often have a hard time understanding the
sort of racial solidarity politics that
organizes a city like Detroit
but look at it from the Black Point of
View uh
all politics has been racialized for
African-Americans and had been for
hundreds of years and those habits of
thought are not going to go away quickly
unfortunately though uh
ethnic solidarity politics
tends to enable some of the worst forms
of government it's not just in
african-american-run cities you see the
same thing in you know old ethnic
Catholic
Democratic machines in uh you know
places like Upper Darby Pennsylvania or
Delaware County
those kinds of places uh this sort of
you know Clan oriented politics
everything from you know reason to
principle to the idea of the rule of law
and everything else gets uh subordinated
to that now in Detroit this led to some
really spectacularly bad outcomes
one of which was called Kwame Kilpatrick
some of you may remember it was the
mayor of Detroit for a long time
currently a resident of Oklahoma where
he is
known as federal prisoner number
44678-039
and uh
you know just looted the city for uh
God knows how much money I don't think
they ever really got a real accounting
of it
uh when Coleman Young was the mayor of
New York and he was a very sort of uh
racially polarizing guy kind of
flamboyant black powder Power sort of
guy
one time explained Detroit's problems as
the money left the city in the back
pockets of the white people
um
his police chief and his Deputy police
chief which to say his number one in his
number two Law Enforcement Officers
between them stole almost three million
dollars from the city
and uh Coleman Young stayed as mayor for
20 years something like that uh the idea
of uh you know accountability
uh just disappears when everything
becomes about uh this one polarizing Us
and Them sort of issue and you see the
same thing in you know places like
Philadelphia
you know some years ago uh
Democrat turned nominal Republican and
in New York we don't know anything about
those
uh by the name of Sam Katz was running
from Aaron Sam cats as you might guess
from his name is Jewish and uh was
running against an African-American
candidate and the level of uh you know
just anti-Semitism and racism and such
that was poured his way for having the
tumerity to seek to be mayor of the city
in which she lived was just shocking
uh you know I saw things there on the
ground covering that that I uh just
never expected to
but in Detroit of course you have a much
more complicated situation because the
city went from being
an almost entirely White City to an
almost entirely black City in a very
very short period of time uh
trying to remember the numbers here
exactly
so from 1960 to 1970 Detroit lost 158
000 residents
on one year it lost something like
twenty two thousand uh people were just
up and moving but the really shocking
thing is even though it only lost on net
662 residents during those same years it
lost 344 000 white residents
uh the white population of Detroit just
basically packed up and left in the
course of a very short period of time
1950 there were 1.5 million white people
living in Detroit today there are 75
000.
uh this sort of polarization
has aspects that aren't always obvious
to people so when you're looking at
who's moving in who's moving out it's
not just a racial thing obviously if you
look at the median household income for
African-American households in Detroit
from 1965 to 1980 it goes like sort of
like that about a 50 degree angle down
and that's not because these households
were suddenly becoming poor it's because
after the white middle class moved out
the black middle class really over the
course of about 12 years just as one got
up and moved left to the suburbs if you
look at the population of the overall
Detroit metro area it hasn't really
changed all that radically in some of
the sub counties around Detroit in fact
have gained population in the last years
but Detroit which was once I guess at
its biggest maybe was the seventh
largest U.S city sixth
was it the fourth wow it's today smaller
than Fort Worth
uh it has just over 700 000 residents
something like that
so 1950 no one was talking about you
know big cities like Fort Worth
uh still known as as Cowtown
so uh
that sort of thing produces really bad
political outcomes and when you have
this sort of us in the mentality the
idea that you're going to go in and uh
have a state government where you have a
white governor and you have City like
Detroit where you've got these unionized
public sector workers who are almost
unanimously African-American who's
overwhelmingly so
there's no way to sort out a democracy
in a place like Detroit without making
it a cultural issue and it becomes a
very very dicey thing and which is one
of the reasons why Detroit's bankruptcy
process has been such a joke
the current retirees who have
I don't know it's 18 billion dollars
that they need to fund their pensions
they don't have have agreed to take a
cut on net of four and a half percent
and plus some you know cost of living
stuff down the road the police
environment are taking no cut
except in their eventual cost of living
adjustments was to go down from Two and
a Half to one percent or something like
that
so my guess is Detroit ends up back in
bankruptcy court in five or ten years
at the most it's been a very politicized
process creditors who should have been
paid were strong-armed uh people who
should have been taking a bigger haircut
because they have political clout were
able to keep that from being done if
you're a real big believer in the rule
of law
it's the sort of thing that is going to
depress you
but there's no way to really put this
just in in economic terms
Detroit has an illegitimacy rate right
now of 85 percent
it has high schools in which the
graduation rates average around 25
percent
uh but there are also Economic
Consequences of that uh Insurance in
Detroit cost about 300 of what it does
across the city line in the uh Suburban
surrounding counties so it becomes a
very very difficult place to live unless
you have so much money that it doesn't
matter unless you have so little money
that it doesn't matter and that's not
really an outcome you want
uh we missed a huge opportunity you know
we had this big post-war boom and that's
what we all think of as normal in the
United States these years from you know
1950 to about the middle 1970s when you
know we were manufacturing Powerhouse
you could get out of high school go get
a job at a factory and buy a house all
this you know largely mythological but
there was something to it
the part of that we always ignore is
that the rest of the world was a smoking
ruin because there had just been this
enormous war and most of the world
surviving manufacturing capacity was
still here in the United States in 1950
the U.S uh was responsible for 60 of the
planet's manufacturing output
we had 61 percent of the total economic
output of the oecd at the time these
were highly unusual times but all of our
assumptions about how we're going to
handle pensions about how we organize
our cities about what our economy can
look like are based on this highly
unusual period of time we're talking
about PJ was talking about the Baby
Boomers that was the world they grew up
in but that's not the real world
in the long term the real per capita
growth in GDP in the United States over
the course of our history averages
around two percent
and anything that is based on more
optimistic uh expectations than that is
probably not going to come to pass
now Detroit
being in the situation it's in is maybe
a little less difficult to swallow
because it has become a relatively small
City
that's my minute and a half warning
and uh some of the other guys will get
into this a little bit more but um you
know you've got a city of 700 000 people
it is the largest city to have gone
bankrupt the largest municipality United
States to go bankrupt but it's still not
that big
um when it's Los Angeles or when it's
the whole state of Illinois or when it's
the whole state of New Jersey you're
going to be in for a whole different set
of problems
and unwinding uh these trillions of
dollars we have in obligations
is a project that there's no historical
precedent for no one knows how it's
going to turn out you've seen debt
crises and financial crises in other
countries but not really for one that's
23 percent of the world's GDP
uh there's no one who can come in and
bail out the United States it just
doesn't work that way uh it's like you
know trying to bail out a whale it's
just not not going to happen so yeah
Detroit I think is a warning about where
things are going but it's going to be
much much worse when it's a big city
when you try to figure out how to
rationalize the finances of a place as
big as Los Angeles which is probably
insolvent uh Los Angeles isn't in
bankruptcy and it's not showing any
signs of going in there right now but it
probably should
um it is way upside down on its
obligations
sorting that out is not something that
anybody has ever done before and there's
no way of knowing how it's going to turn
out so the thing that economists worry
about often is uncertainty these are
indeed very uncertain times
thank you
[Applause]
Kevin your job was supposed to make us
hopeful
so we're going to leave that to Wayne
um
I'm going to fail in that okay
Wayne Weingarten has 20 years of
experience in business economics and
politics and a PhD from George Mason
University his policy research examines
the impact from fiscal and Regulatory
policies on economic growth
his columns have been published in the
Wall Street Journal Chicago Tribune
Investors Business Daily and Forbes
he's testified in front of Congress
he's worked around the world including
Hong Kong and New York and as a policy
analyst in Washington D.C he's currently
a partner with capital economic advisors
and a senior fellow at the Pacific
Research Institute he is going to join
us and give us a case study of three
cities in Chicago
who are hopefully working their way
through bankruptcy thank you very much
Wayne
foreign
[Applause]
actually California not not Chicago but
you did but that's okay
um I wish I had an optimistic message I
really do uh picking up where Kevin left
off Los Angeles uh that actually is uh a
great connection between Detroit and
these three California cities Vallejo I
apologize for my pronunciation there
Vallejo uh San Bernardino in Stockton
um there's a pattern you know Mark Twain
said that history uh it doesn't repeat
itself but it Rhymes and right now you
see this rhyme between the cities
Detroit has had a very similar pattern
in some ways that Vallejo has had and
it's gone through bankruptcies back out
San Bernardino has gone through the same
pattern so with Stockton well Los
Angeles really it is on the exact same
train track it's just a a few years
behind and what I want to do with you
today is go through some of the numbers
I'm an economist I apologize so I'm
gonna bore you some numbers but I wanted
to walk what is that pattern what should
we be looking for when we're looking at
these municipalities because it is a
crisis I wish I could be optimistic but
there is a crisis and for these cities
it's worse because not only is there a
municipal crisis but there's a state
crisis you may have heard that
California doesn't Implement uh the best
state policies that are out there uh in
fact prop 30 I don't know is anyone here
familiar with what prop 30 has brought
basically prop 30 decided they call it
the millionaires tax but uh if you live
in California after you pay all your
federal income taxes and with the AMT
you probably need to pay your full state
taxes as well you have to pay another
13.3 percent uh to the state government
which is pretty outrageous actually Phil
Mickelson he had the gall to say that
was excessive uh and uh quickly
apologize because how dare he say that
but it actually cost him 1.8 million
dollars
seems a bit excessive to me Tiger Woods
right before he went pro you guys know
where he lived California where did he
move to Florida why no income tax if you
look what prop 30 would have done he
saved in 2012 alone Tiger Woods save 12
and a half million dollars
twelve and a half million dollars
because he lived in Florida not in
California so you know what this relates
to for the cities is two things one
these cities have a problem in and of
themselves because they've had a
terrible State and they've got to wear
that all around their neck and that's
that's that's difficult to deal with
but the other issue is what is the one
of the ultimate Arbiters of where you
know of of how good an economy is Right
Detroit had the same thing do people
want to live there right people want to
live in places that they say okay this
is a good place good strong quality of
life good public services and I can keep
a large portion of my money so I can
decide where I want to spend it how I
want to allocate it well California 13.3
percent at State taxed alone you really
don't have that option so for those of
you who aren't familiar with California
geography
it's not quite up yet there it is this
is where the um the cities are so uh
Stockton and uh Vallejo are really on
the Outer Banks of uh of San Francisco
area where Stockton's down by La one of
the things they have in common is
they're not essential cities right
they're kind of a far distance away from
kind of the the main area of this San
Francisco or LA
now there's a certain pattern or certain
kind of similarity that those cities
have and the same similarities with
Detroit and it's the same thing we think
about Los Angeles uh going down that
same path and the very first thing is if
you are fiscally insolvent and this goes
whether it's a personal uh bankruptcy
whether it's a corporate bankruptcy or
whether it's Municipal bankruptcy right
if you personally go bankrupt but you
leave off the very expensive sports car
and the payment you have on that sports
car you're not going to be financially
sustainable
well the same thing goes with the cities
up until now and it's beginning to
change we'll get in that in a few
moments pensions have been considered
special right they are an obligation
probably you know I would argue an
obligation no different than any type of
bond contract you went into
but up until now by law they have been
different and vallejo's biggest mistake
in Detroit's biggest mistake has been
that they have not fully dealt with
their unfunded pension problem and these
municipalities will never become
fiscally sustainable in the long term
without dealing with pension it kind of
goes back to PGA work and the Baby
Boomers right this is all intermingled
but our municipalities will not be
stable until that pension issue is dealt
with it's it's one in the same issue
the other uh big lesson is that the
economy matters
right we can see when we go through
Vallejo both before they declare
bankruptcy as well as after their
economy continued to underperform you
will never be able to restore your
fiscal sovereignty if you don't have a
vibrant economy or have a growing
economy so uh for instance San
Bernardino okay no Stockton when they uh
part of their plan they're raising sales
taxes well just at a time when your
reputational effect is being impacted
and people are leaving the city you know
raising taxes in the last few people
working is probably not the best
strategy for revitalizing the economy so
taking care of your economy matters as
well
and the other fact which I think should
be obvious but for some reason isn't is
the idea that chapter nine is not a
solution right people say okay well we
declared chapter nine so we'll be okay
no chapter nine is the beginning of a
process
right and there's a few key issues that
I wanted to share with you in chapter
nine I think some of you may be familiar
but just to make sure we're all on the
same page with this
we talk about why declare chapter nine
what's the point the only uh benefit
that a municipality gets from declaring
chapter nine bankruptcy is they get time
breathing room and a Judicial structure
right that in effect forces all of your
creditors to sit down in an organized
way you're not bleeding money everyone
can be calm and you can then figure out
okay
who who gets what haircut and that's
really what you're talking about right
we you can't get blood from a stone we
don't have enough money to pay everyone
back
right now part of of course then this is
where the pension issue comes in if you
take all of your pension obligations off
the table if you're a bondholder then
the haircut you need to take is just
going to be increased dollar for dollar
for every pension dollar you bring off
right so but that's all you get from uh
from declaring chapter nine is that
judicial process to kind of deal with
your debts and there's a tremendous
amount of costs right the first one
which probably makes a lot of sense is
that if you declare bankruptcy we're
going to call you a a higher credit risk
right I mean I I wouldn't go out and
lend money to Vallejo California right
now
um so the credit risk should go down the
interest cost goes up that's a that's a
very large cost that all municipalities
have to pay
the other issue of course is then the
the damage to the image we make fun of
Detroit now we make fun of Orange County
of Vallejo of Stockton so your image
suffers and that image suffering can
lead to a vicious circle the vicious
circle of course being residents leave
that Resident leaving reduces your tax
base with the lower tax base tax revenue
start to go down all of this starts to
Circle and so what you haven't seen in
any of these cities which is very
important difficult to do in California
but a key lesson is okay what do we do
to attract people back to our city we
know we've declared bankruptcy right San
Bernardino is one of the most beautiful
places in the country
right there's a lot of natural factors
that should be encouraging people to
live to San Bernardino how do we
leverage that to get people activity
jobs back to the city and without that
consideration right again your Municipal
bankruptcy is not going to be successful
so that is a kind of a oh oh I'm sorry
one thing I also wanted to mention which
is uh a unique fact of chapter nine
compared to uh uh
bankruptcy for corporations for
individuals and that is the idea that
you can't force in when you're in
chapter 9 bankruptcy you can't be forced
to uh liquidate any assets you can't be
forced to you know so in a corporate
bankruptcy for instance right you can
shut the company down right you can't do
that in municipality municipalities are
as long as someone's living there there
are services that need to be provided if
those Services need to be provided they
have to have the revenues and the
ability to do that
also Additionally the policy decisions
are not supposed to be made by the court
I know that might sound a bit ridiculous
but in theory that's what the case is
supposed to be so again you can't force
uh policy on the municipality through
the bankruptcy proceedings so that makes
uh chapter 9 a bit different than other
bankruptcies and more importantly for
the municipalities it gives them better
negotiating leverage so when you see
this inability for the uh municipalities
to get rid of the pensions well they're
they're in a much better negotiating
position they should be able to kind of
affect that change and hopefully we'll
see in a couple of rulings with Detroit
and there was a ruling with respect to
Stockton that might hopefully give us
some hope in that in that area
so if you look at Vallejo is a perfect
case study of public Choice economics
right I studied economics at George
Mason and we we like public choice we
think it's a very good way of viewing
the world and
in Vallejo you had a very very powerful
public unions and I think that's a
commonality across most uh
municipalities and in this case what you
had firefighters were paying 230 a month
in Union dues yet police officers they
paid 254 dollars a month we build that
overtime over again and again what you
end up with is a very powerful Public
Employee Union and so what they
negotiated were and I kind of put some
of those numbers in bold for you I think
there's some pretty outrageous salaries
there was a police captain who made over
three hundred thousand dollars a year I
know you're in the outer areas of San
Francisco but I still think that's a bit
uh excessive you know the average
firefighter was making north of 170 000
a year they also had the gold-plated
pensions which you qualify for within
five years and you also had this
wonderful little payout option where if
you didn't use your vacation days when
you retired you got to cash out the
value of that and so again people with
their incentives they figure these
things out you end up gaming the system
you're talking about in some cases and
these are the extremes but you know 370
000 in payouts so what you had in effect
is a a Public Employee unit in effect
took over the system they were they were
demanding excessive salaries they were
demanding excessive uh benefits and
through a compliant uh city council they
were able to get it and I love the um
mayor Davis's quote I have it up there I
can't quite see it he goes if you if you
have a can that's leaking two ounces a
minute and you put an ounce a minute in
it it's going to get empty right and and
that's it that's exactly what happened
and you can see economically going into
uh when they declare bankruptcy they
declared bankruptcy in 2008 they had a
slight decline in population every year
that's that small little black line that
every year
0.03 you know three basis points a
slight decline but in fact a stagnant
population right and on top of that you
had the economy was growing much slower
than the US average in this case we're
talking about 1.6 slower so you had a
slow growing economy and a declining
population people are not choosing to
live in Vallejo and that shows up in
their budget so here what you have is
you have the expenditures of the City of
Vallejo in the black line and in the
blue dotted line we have what their
revenues are and you can see that
from 2004 to 2008 when they're when
they're forced to declare bankruptcy
their revenues are going down they're
declining economy is not allowing them
to have any type of growth in their tax
base now they didn't align their
expenditures with it and that was uh
combined with the housing bust right
kind of a shock and that's kind of one
of the patterns you see there's an
economic shock that pushes the
municipality over in this case we had
the Great Recession it pushed over a
Vaio it could no longer you know play
games switch things around move money
from one bucket to another so they were
out of options and had to declare
bankruptcy
but going into that you had that
fundamental problem of a excessive costs
right as well as kind of a declining uh
tax revenue base
now you can't say that Vallejo didn't
try or didn't cut spending and that's
the really interesting thing about the
case study when you look at what they
did they cut Services dramatically my
favorite quote and I kind of have it up
there on uh in bold where they asked
residents and this is in an area that's
got higher crime than average right so
you have a high crime city and they ask
a residents to use the 911 system
judiciously I don't know what
judiciously used in that moment system
is but I guess if you can drive yourself
to the hospital when you're having a
heart attack that's what they would
recommend
um
they they cut the number of police
officers almost by 40 percent they cut
all sorts of services you know they cut
the youth groups they cut service
centers they stopped doing any type of
infrastructure development so you're
talking about really cutting into the
bone they're reducing the quality of
life kind of services that would make
somebody want to live in Vallejo right
so you can't say that they did not do uh
Cuts or they didn't cut spending they
did and you can actually see that when
you look at their expenditures right
ever since they went bankrupt their
expenditures plummeted okay the the
problem is they didn't touch the
pensions and that's kind of our
recurring theme here they didn't cut the
pensions and so
uh the problem wasn't solved
so a few things are happening now one is
that population uh Exodus has
accelerated it was before we had a
slight uh decline in population now it's
becoming you know more than just a
trickle so people are choosing not to
live in Vallejo now of course you have
the broader California kind of Trends
pushing them out as well but uh there's
certainly the the impact in the
municipal bankruptcy is there too and
you have an extreme this is again
relative so a Great Recession is here
but it's relative to the rest of the
country and extreme economic
underperformance so the the city
economically is doing worse which is
what you would predict right when they
went into bankruptcy you would they
didn't do anything to kind of uh
encourage greater growth and the result
is a severe decline in growth people
choosing to leave following Services
following revenues
and most importantly their budget's
still not stable
this is from the oh I apologize for
blocking part of it this is from the
Aveo City's budget and this is their
projections this is what they expect
this is probably you can almost imagine
a best case scenario over the next 10
years okay through 2020 actually next
six years right and they they imagine
that their revenues are going to be very
small they're not going to get much
growth in Revenue which is probably
correct they're trying to Tamp down on
their expenditures but the big thing
that kind of jumps off in that chart is
the huge you know over eight percent
increase in pension costs
so that their pensions which are
currently about 13 of their general fund
expenditures are going to grow to 20
over 20 21 of the budget and that's
probably their best case scenario
okay which basically means that the the
city is still financially insolvent
right they they went through and endured
all the costs associated with declaring
chapter chapter 9 bankruptcy they went
through all the things cut bondholders
got a haircut by 50 you know police
officers got pink slips you know
Services were not performed and yet
they're going to end up right back in
bankruptcy just like Detroit we'll be
back in the same situation because they
didn't address the underlying causes
okay now
for uh Stockton California in San
Bernardino and I'm not going to bore you
going through the same process over and
over again but if you look at kind of
what's happened it's the same thing
there was the economic shock all of them
suffered from the Great Recession but
that shock was just what pushed them
over the problem was they were fiscally
unsound and they're fiscally unsound
because of the pension problem
uh and therefore when they were in a
position where they could no longer
manage those um
right that difference anymore they went
into bankruptcy so the lesson I'm going
to skip ahead to that because we are
running out of time a little bit you can
just see these charts kind of again it's
the same uh uh the same patterns over
and over again is that
you have to understand and watch for
those kind of weakening economic
fundamentals we talked about Los Angeles
Los Angeles isn't on that same path if
you look at their pension problem it's
tremendous it actually makes vaio's
painting a problem look uh small in
comparison right they have it is in news
today about their budget deficit they
can't get that under control right when
the next economic shock hits right not
if but when that next economic shock
hits like hurricanes in Florida you know
they're going to come Los Angeles really
needs to be on the kind of the watch
list because they're in bad enough shape
that they may not be able to withstand
that storm right the the the the lesson
is what you need to do is you need to
one what if I hear you did you need to
address your expenditure problems you
need to bring salaries in line you need
to address those problems but what you
also need to do is you need to get the
patient under control now that's very
easy for an academic to say we were
actually having this conversation uh
before the prison today getting the
pensions under control right now Most
states offer what they call defined
benefits programs and is everyone
familiar with that basically they say
we'll pay you five thousand dollars a
month for the rest of your life once you
retire and a lot of these places you can
retire 55 60 some very young age
those are unaffordable those are not
going to be able to those promises are
not going to be able to be fulfilled the
problem is what they should move to is
the defined contribution plan to find
contribution says we'll give you two
thousand dollars you can save it do you
know whatever you want with it and take
care of your own retirement that's in
the in the private sector that's what
most people have to find contribution
here's the kicker and here's the problem
if you switch all the public employees
over from a defined benefit plan to
Define contribution plan you take out
all the young workers
right that's the base of our Ponzi
scheme right if you have a Ponzi scheme
you need new money to come in in order
to to pay the people at the top so if we
all of a sudden just say okay let's get
everyone into a defined benefit plan
what you've just done you just told the
municipality they need to spend
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars if not more in order to uh kind
of pay off the promises that they've
already made and so that's kind of the
track I said it's not I I wish I could
be optimistic but I guess I'm an
economist so I'm supposed to be
pessimistic right so it's not a pretty
situation the first step though has to
be uh freezing the current system so you
know if you're if you're in a hole the
first step is to stop digging right and
so that's really you know with
practically what's the first thing to do
you've got to freeze the pension systems
and you've got to take an assessment of
kind of how large the problem is and you
know there's different Creative
Solutions out there that we need to work
toward in order to move that current
unfunded liability into something that
is uh affordable and that fair to both
the taxpayers as well as the pensioners
and I have seven seconds left so I guess
I'll I'll wield that back to the chair
thank you
thank you Wayne
we've piled it all upon the shoulders of
our next panelist Rick Baker
but I'm actually confident that he will
give us some reason for optimism
because Rick has done it he has done it
and in 2001 Rick Baker was elected mayor
of Saint Petersburg which is Florida's
fourth largest city
under mayor Baker's leadership Saint
Petersburg experienced a Renaissance as
its downtown became one of the most
vibrant in the southeast
he's received numerous awards for his
leadership in Saint Petersburg including
being named America's mayor of the Year
by governing magazine
he has an MBA and a law degree with
honors from Florida State University and
studied comparative law at Oxford and
also served as a legal intern on
Florida's Supreme Court
he's an adjunct Feller fellow of the
Manhattan Institute
and the author of this book The seamless
City a book about City leadership and
urban revitalization
mayor Baker now serves as the president
of Edwards group a saint
petersburg-based group of companies
involved in development hotels real
estate entertainment and hospitality
Rick the floor is yours
[Applause]
thank you Chris
I'm depressed
I was going to give a great talk but I'm
really depressed I know I thank you
Wayne and thank you Kevin
um I I'm very happy to be here uh for a
couple reasons and I I enjoyed all the
talks today I I should disclose
something I I uh well I was mayor a few
years ago we we uh when I went down with
ESPN to Fort Lauderdale to try to get a
college bowl game to come to St
Petersburg that's what Mayors do they
try to bring stuff to the city for
economic development other reasons and
we succeeded we got a bowl game to come
to St Pete and and it's been there for a
number of years and I just found out
recently there was an announcement that
the bowl game received a new sponsor and
a new name for the bowl game so this
December our college bowl game in St
Petersburg is going to be called the
Bitcoin Bowl so
that is a true story and and I I uh I'm
now trying to figure out was it some
Japanese guy we don't know that's doing
it or what I don't know but I I
yesterday I had the opportunity to meet
with bitpay folks who were trying to
work in our shopping center that's a
whole other topic been paid related to
bitcoin and so in the process I signed
up for Bitcoin and I got my first twenty
dollar wallet Bitcoin uh and and after
this morning's talk I'm wondering am I
going to have an IRS problem now is it
do I have to do a report for I think
that's what they said this morning so I
may have to get rid of that Bitcoin it
is it is uh honored to be here with
these great panelists it's honored to be
at Hillsdale College I I
am kind of an endangered species you
know you I'm a social and fiscal
conservative that was mayor of large
city
there aren't too many of those in the
country and I can tell you that when you
are in that position to have groups like
Hillsdale College that that put ideas on
the table you know Jeb Bush was a great
governor of Florida as a good friend of
mine and he he talks about the power of
great ideas and that's what Hillsdale is
doing it Gathering folks together
discussing debating and I and I'm I'm
very very appreciative I can't tell you
how much uh how helpful it is to have
Hillsdale and thank you for having me
here
you know you just uh heard the talks and
and and uh I I
I I I I I
kind of personalize it because I've sat
in the seat for nine years
and and imagine
that you are the mayor of a city
and you've got your group of advisors
around your outside Auditors your
financial folks your accountants your
political advisors everybody around the
table and you've been going over the
books of the city
and all of a sudden you come to the
conclusion that you've got to declare
bankruptcy for your city
that's a hard day
that is a very very tough moment to go
through and you wonder how do you how
does a city get to that and we've heard
a little bit about it but how does the
city get to the point where a city's got
to declare bankruptcy by the way we're
the good stories Saint Pete's doing
great I should start out by saying that
so people aren't thinking oh here's the
third bill but but but how does a city
get to that point
well I think it it can be external you
know you have might have an auto
industry that's pulling back and you
might lose jobs in that City that's
going to hurt things you got like in
Philadelphia you might have a shipyard
that closes down and you're trying to
figure out how to backfill that and
those are issues but I think a lot of
the issues as you've heard are
self-inflicted
you you have poor leadership I think
almost talk about any business any
organization of any kind any City if you
have poor leadership it's not going to
advance very far so if you have a leader
come in
and they say okay I I'm going to bring
all my political friends with me to give
them six-figure figure jobs because
they've never had that before and we're
going to put them into these
administrative positions in the city
which happens we know that happens and
and then and then are they going to be
effective are they going to provide the
services
that the city needs at the Quality
that's the city needs no not going to
happen at the same time you do the
unions are very involved in the
political process at the mayor's level
but also at the city council level and
the unions I think have even more
influence on the city council level
because not that many folks get involved
in city council elections so you can
have a disproportionate influence on it
so they do and then afterwards of course
their their their job is to advocate for
pay-in benefits and conditions for their
their people that are in their unions so
in order to keep getting reelected you
you pay more and you you give more
benefits and sometimes you give pension
benefits because again you might not
even have to pay for that until down the
road and so that the costs start to
climb and the costs go up and up and up
so you have Services going down and
costs going up and then the cost go up
so the the simplistic solution to that
if you're on the liberal side raise tax
rates because you got to be able to get
those costs in so you're tax rates so
you raise tax rates and and actually
when you have a boom like we just had it
it exacerbates it because you have more
revenues coming in than is natural
because your ad form revenues are going
up because your property values are
higher your sales tax are going up
because you have this big boom Going On
and and so because you have all these
revenues going in if you don't have
discipline then you start finding ways
to spend it so you add employees to the
city
give more benefits and you give more
costs and and and it's so at some point
you hit a wall you have uh as Wayne said
the the you hit a Great Recession and
two things happen in a recession one is
is your revenues go down right sales tax
revenues property tax so you've
increased all these expenses
to match these increasing revenues and
all of a sudden your revenue is dropped
guess what your expenses don't drop
so that happens and then your pension
accounts
get devalued because the market crashes
so you so you've got your protection a
lot of Pensions down 30 35 25 so when
that happens you have to increase your
Actuarial payments to the pension
accounts you have a spike in expenses
beyond the high expenses you already
have and and it gets to be a downward
spiral because when expenses when taxes
go up and services go down people leave
and and if and and as as that that
continues to spiral down it's very very
hard
to pull out of that when I was uh before
I ran for mayor in 2001 I had written a
book on the history of Florida and St
Petersburg and I really studied
at that time the periods of the boom and
and it and the crash in the 20s and 30s
in Florida because that was a very
significant part of our state's history
so what happened was in the 20s you had
the lot boom in Florida and the lockdown
was you had developers that we had a lot
of tourists coming and you had
developers come in and they subdivided
these orange groves into residential
single-family home lots okay and they
sold these Lots but they weren't selling
them for people moving they were selling
them as Investments they were selling to
people coming in and say you know these
lots have been going up every year in
value and if you buy them now you can
sell them next year you can pay for both
vacations and it doesn't cost so the lot
values started going up and up and up
and up well in order to in order to uh
pay for the infrastructure for those
lots the city of Saint Pete issued bonds
and the bonds went to pay for brick
roads and water and sewer to cover all
of these subdivided Lots in the City
bridges to go to some of our Barrier
Island residential areas so to the point
where Saint Pete before the crash had
the second highest Bond per capita of
debt in the country behind Atlantic City
back at the time so then the the these
Lots kept going up and up and up and up
and up in a good value until as one
developer back then said we ran out of
suckers
so so what it it crashed the whole thing
in 1925 four years before the stock
market crash the real estate industry in
Florida correct it was so bad that there
were attorney generals in northern
states that were freezing accounts so
that their residents of their states
could not send money down to Florida to
buy Lots that's how that's how bad it
was so so in 25 we had a real estate
depression and then in 29 we had the
Great Depression stock market crash I
used to I like to say St Pete boom like
nobody else boom during the 20s and it
crashed like nobody else crashed in the
in the in the in the Great Depression
every Bank in the city went out of
business of course like everywhere else
in the country widespread unemployment
couldn't pay our bonds couldn't pay rent
so we kind of bled our way through the
30s until uh uh they we had a
refinancing plan and it was a very
detailed 1937 refinancing the plan which
because I'm a fun guy I read and studied
and it was it it talked about how the
city eventually pulled its way up now
why do I talk about that
because I came to the conclusion before
I ran for as I was running for office
and and and from my experience in the
city
that that the the issue in advancing the
city and the finances of a city are are
twofold first is when you have a boom
and if you know the history of Florida
you know they're going to be booms and
busts so you've got to plan for the bus
when you have a boom that's when you
plan for the bust
that's important people didn't do that
but that's when you do it and the second
thing you need to understand is that yes
there are individual aspects the pension
is a critical the whole discussion of
defined benefit versus defined
contribution I get I understand I agree
with it's it's a tough issue and and
it's and it's and it's a big issue in
the financial aspects of things but
there are other issues and and what a
city if you have a Detroit a city like
Detroit which lost I think from 1950
today something like 1 million people or
a city like St Louis at that same period
of time lost a half a million people
Philadelphia Baltimore what do you do
with all those empty houses what do you
do with those empty neighborhoods I mean
you could fix the pension plans in in
Detroit tomorrow which would be a good
thing you're still going to have a lot
of problems you're going to still have
economic problems you're going to have
crime problems you're going to have a
lot of problems so the way we approach
governance in St Pete and that's it's
really what my my book seamless city is
about it's it's how do you develop a
strategic plan for running a business
you know uh Wayne and I were talking
earlier in business
you start talking about strategic
planning and people just say well of
course you do that but not so much in
government and and they but they should
so we developed a strategic plan for
running our city and it started with a
mission statement we set a goal of of of
building the best city in America by
working every day to make the quality of
life for the people living there great
now people will always tell me well yeah
that's easy to say best in America you
know you you can't measure that you
can't and my response is you know if I
set a goal of becoming the fourth best
city in Florida
who's going to follow me right so so so
people but people follow Quests for
excellence
resources come to Quest For Excellence
people want to be part if you're working
to become the best at something people
want to become it so then we identified
five strategic areas within that mission
statement that we were going after
Public Safety
Economic Development
schools neighborhoods and government
services and and finances okay so uh
Public Safety number one job of of any
mayor in any city in the country if the
public safety is no going well if your
crime rates are not going up if you if
kids are afraid to come out of their
house you're not going to move that City
where anywhere you're never going to get
people moving in or businesses your
economics are never going to take off
you have to do that you have to focus on
that number one job and it's by the way
the police officers is the toughest job
in the city you know we we talk a lot
about pensions and issues like that I
get that I understand it police officer
is The Toughest Job In The City the
second the second uh issue schools we we
put in in place a a very expansive
program to support our public schools
and say because you know I ran from here
I said I'm going to advocate for the
schools and work for the schools and
people say why are you doing that
because that's not under the city in
most cities the schools aren't under the
city
my response was if the schools aren't
good people aren't going to move into
your community and they're and the
businesses aren't going to come to your
community and you're never going to
advance the city economically and you're
never going to get your finances and
Patrol if your schools are not good so
in Florida you may know Governor Bush
that the a plus program where we grade
our schools every school a b c d f based
on the student achievement scores of the
students in the schools I think that's
how you should do it by the way I think
you should determine if a school's doing
well based on the achievement scores of
the kids other people have other
criteria I think they're crazy this one
I think is the work so what we did is we
pattern after that we put programs in
place to support our public schools and
I could talk at length about them but I
won't but I'll but suffice it to say
that at the end of the day our our
elementary schools one half from having
zero a out of 27 elementary schools to
16 a elementary schools out of 27. the
number of A and B schools went up by 260
percent you have to advance your schools
it's a critical part of advancing the
overall City you cannot turn a city
around without turning around the
schools in the city our neighborhoods we
did a lot in neighborhood we have 110
form neighborhood associations in the
city of Saint Pete we advance the
neighborhoods and we put programs in
place I know it's a finance stock but
but the quality of life is key
if you don't have good quality of life
people won't live there businesses won't
come there I've been I've been able to
get businesses to come to St Petersburg
big businesses solely on the basis of
quality of life other cities and other
states were given their more Economic
Development money we we sold quality of
life and we want and that's how you keep
your city vibrant moving forward so we
did things like bike paths we built the
largest bike path system in the
southeast United States we've been
we made a commitment to build a
playground within a half mile walk of
every child in the city we did Parks we
became a designated Green City we did uh
skateboard parks we we did dog parks dog
parks I love dog parks we did that we
had in two days we opened we one day we
we uh uh broke ground on a two million
dollar Library
about a dozen people came the next day
we cut the ribbon on a nine thousand
dollar dog park
fence bench
fire hydrant excuse
200 people showed up for that ribbon
cutting for that dog park they wore out
the grass the neighbor started saying
get these people out of our neighborhood
they're wearing autographs and I'm
thinking
okay they're cheap everybody loves them
I would like to get reelected
we're going to build a lot of dog parks
and we've got dog parks always stay safe
so so you you work on things to improve
the neighborhoods that believe it or not
is tied to the finances because you
can't you can't separate the stuff you
got to do it all and uh Economic
Development as as Chris said we have I I
will say to anybody from Florida we have
the most vibrant nighttime weekend
downtown the State of Florida today it
is it is a very exciting place to be
ought to all come down visit us it's uh
St Petersburg has become cool with the
nightlife and the sidewalk cafes and the
art number one our number one art city
in America for cities under a half a
million and that's 99.5 of the cities in
the country so lots going on in the in
the economic development downtown I
could talk a long time ago about that
alone government services and taxes
so during the boom we tried to do things
that that would would
prepare us for the bust and and so we we
uh we had to increase the number of
police officers and pay the police
officers because the other jurisdictions
around us paid much more and we're
stealing our police officers on a
regular basis and we could not get to
full strength we ended in full strength
but that was the main expenditure we
made but we also reduced positions in
the city in order to help pay for that
we reduced 300 positions in the city
half Professional Management that was 10
of the city staff during this period of
time uh and and and since we increased
the number of police uniforms which is
the most amount of police it's most
amount of employees we really it's far
more than 10 percent of the employees
that we reduced that gave us a pot of
money uh we also uh had new revenues
from the uh from the expansion the
Renaissance we had going on so we then
spent that by uh reducing tax rates by
20 almost 20 percent now that was a very
popular thing as well believe it not
popular everywhere and believe it or not
it was hard to do but we did and and we
had the discipline during the boom to to
reduce Staffing to reduce tax rates and
then to uh uh almost quadruple our
emergency reserves we created an
emergency Reserve Fund in order to get
to the point where we we could do that
so so at the end of the day we we when
the when the when the when the bus hit
we were able to to get through it now
I fully acknowledged I didn't start
where Detroit started when I took over
as mayor of some of the other cities
around the country but I think there is
a path for cities but it's not a simple
solution there are no Simple Solutions
it takes a strategic approach to any
City that you're in with some some
strong and I think committed leadership
in order to make it and I'm going to
close with with something that that may
seem unrelated but it's not
you have to lift
an entire city
the the concept of seamless City
is is an objective that we sent uh set
up when I took office you should not
have seams in your city there shouldn't
be places where you cross a scene
whether it is a road or a neighborhood
boundary or an interstate or a rail
whatever
and enter a place you don't want to be
enter a place where you got to lock your
door you feel like you got a lock your
door you see prostitutes or drug dealers
on the street corner it's it's just the
bad part of town a place where where
there's no hope for the kids you know if
there should be no place in any City
where kids are growing up in a
neighborhood where they're afraid to go
outside
it's not their fault and if and if I
don't want my kids growing up in that
neighborhood nobody's kids should have
to grow up in that neighborhood so we
set about an effort
to work towards seamless City with an
effort towards Midtown which was the the
that part of our city
um largely African-American Democrat
low-income economically depressed part
of our city and we had a tremendous
turnaround in that City now I can tell
you that you have no reason to believe
me because you know you weren't there
you're not probably not been to Midtown
and but I can tell you a statistic
that's going to make you understand what
we were able to do there I am a a
conservative social fiscal conservative
I ran in 2001 and when I ran in the
Midtown precincts uh I the I people put
on my yard signs they they spray painted
in bed with Jim
and they put them all through the
Midtown community and and that part of
the community Was Won by the chairman of
the African people's Socialist Party
okay that was my starting point
so we put an effort not to gentrify that
part of the community but to lift that
particular make the make the quality of
life better because you have to have the
whole Community lifting if you're going
to get if you're going to be able to
make it all work and at the end of the
day I ran for a re-election four years
later
cities 29 Republican against the
chairman of the Democratic Party we want
every Precinct in the city with a 71
vote but what I'm most proud about
we won the Midtown African-American
Democratic precincts by 90 percent
now tell me
whether they think that we made a
difference in changing it to work
towards building this seamless City and
making the city Thrive thank you and I
look forward to thank you
thank you
thank you Rick that was very helpful we
do have time for questions and if you'll
raise your hand someone will bring a
microphone to you we do ask that you
wait for that so that people who are not
in the room today can enjoy this entire
session and while we're waiting for that
I'm going to ask Wayne for a point of
clarification actually I think you're
you're the one for this if if um
section 9
doesn't allow
for courts to make tough choices and
we're not getting it from City
leadership
and that's going to put us back in
bankruptcy again what are the options to
imposing different bankruptcy choices
that can put Power in the hands of
courts or outside
authorities beyond the city
yes John the um the courts are actually
beginning to rule uh in favor of
pensions being an asset that can be
renegotiated uh in bankruptcy so judge
Klein in terms of Stockton's bankruptcy
has just ruled that there's app that
bankruptcy law should supersede the
California Constitution and in fact that
pension obligations are no different
they end up Bond obligations I believe
Detroit has had the same the judges
ruled in the same way so pension
obligations are beginning to be
considered just any other obligation
into they can be I I think
uh part of the the refinancing it's
still developing but there are some
optimistic aspects there okay where are
the questions right here in the Center
I'll address this to uh mayor Baker a
couple of things that came out of
hearing all of these talks were first of
all
the importance of
um giving your word be careful what you
promise because you may be held
accountable
for that promise
and again I'd just like to
hear how you deal with that the second
thing which is similar and IT addresses
this pension plan is thinking long term
in terms of your decisions not just
short term obviously there's a tendency
to always think short term and not long
term another thing I'd be interested in
hearing is the importance of home
ownership in voters taking a
responsibility for what happens in their
communities in other words the greater
the home ownership the more
responsibility there is among the voters
and the last thing is
your relationship with the city council
whatever type of government you have I
know in the community I'm in there's
sometimes a very uh difficult
relationship between the the mayor and
the city council could you keep the mic
because I don't think I wrote them all
down so I'm going to start with the last
one and I'll go back as many as I can
remember
um I
yeah
Florida is a uh has a has a very
aggressive Sunshine Law which means that
no two City Council Members can talk to
each other about any issue that could
come before the city on the telephone in
person at all
in a strong former government by the way
St Pete's a strong mayor former
government probably the vast majority of
cities in America are not strong mayor
former government uh then that means
that the mayor is just one vote on city
council and they hire a city manager to
run the city strong mayor of the mayor's
political leader and runs the city we
probably have a half a dozen out of 400
cities in Florida our strong mayor forms
of government in in our government which
is one of those uh the mayor is not on
Council so is not subject to the
Sunshine Law so the mayor has the
ability which I did to go talk to
individual city council members on an
ongoing basis in
and I tried to uh I had I had great
success with city council and they had
success with me I I we we were to I
think we really felt and saw it as a
team and I if they had issues for
instance I had one that was in
transportation I tell them I had a
transportation talk to him work with
them let me know what's going on but
work with that council member if there
was one that was an interested in
environmental issues I put my folks
related to that and work with the city
council and we really
really had very few issues I I want we
had impasse hearings as you do in Union
negotiations I actually
um uh argued that the the final argument
at the impasse hearing to try to make a
point in which we were successful at at
prevailing on so as far as your
long-term issue that's a tough issue
it's uh that you know we talked a lot
about pension we haven't talked too much
about post retirement medical benefits
which are another big issue and they
just the the the uh so the national
government CPA Group is now only now
made it so cities have to be accountable
and put it on their books how much the
UN unfunded uh deferred medical is and
and so one one thing we did is we ended
it for for new hires and and uh and and
continued for others that was very
not easy to do the pension issues are
very not easy to do but you have to you
have to look at the long term you have
to look at the financial viability of
the city and you'd have to try to get
leadership that's going to do that it's
not it's not easy to do that you had two
other ones I'm not remembering
well one was home ownership the
importance of home ownership uh is is a
you know I think homeownership is an
aspiration
but but not all people could afford to
own homes
and I think that you know if if if one
one of the issues we've just gone
through in a national economy was a
situation where there are a lot of
people with a lot of mortgages that had
no business having mortgages
and at the end of the day that bit us
very hard so so while I do believe home
ownership should be an aspiration there
are some folks when they're starting out
when they're getting going they rent I
rented when I was young as you start out
you rent until you can save someone I I
kind of believe people ought to save for
a deposit before they buy a house you
know and and be able to afford to pay it
so I believe in home ownership but it's
got to be tempered with the fact that
people have to be able to pay the
mortgages
hi uh Matt buffton from The Institute
for liberal studies now in Ottawa but
originally from Windsor right across the
river from Detroit so my question is for
Kevin uh when I speak to my friends in
Michigan what a lot of them suggest is
that I'm glad you pointed out the
suburbs around Detroit are at least
functional in most cases uh maybe it's
uh you know they're surviving if not
thriving a lot of a common suggestion is
that those suburbs should sort of start
to engulf Detroit and you you peel off a
bit of the city that's not working at
all and you make it part of a suburban
community that is working at least
better I wonder if you have any thoughts
on what that could be a effective
solution
um
it sounds like you're asking the suburbs
to give themselves the political and
economic equivalent of a venereal
disease
well you know what what would be in it
for them I mean no seriously uh why
would you want to Annex uh a place
that's got you know the sorts of
problems and not much to add
um I think it would be a pretty
unpopular idea I was mentioning this
last night there's a novel I'm very fond
of called Infinite Jest by David Foster
Wallace it's kind of a science fiction
thing and part of the story is that in
the near future parts of Northern New
England have become so polluted that we
force Canada to Annex them and
um
that sounds a little bit like what
you're talking about I did have
something you want to add on that
question of home ownership just because
there's an interesting point about that
my colleague Ryan Salam did a piece on
this a couple of years ago there are
social benefits that are associated with
home ownership
but only in situations in which people
have a lot of equity uh those benefits
do not materialize in you know sort of
zero down no equity in the house upside
down uh kind of relationships the uh
stability and Civic engagement and that
sort of thing that tends to be
associated with home ownership is more
Associated more closely associated with
home equity
um you'll notice that my my native Texas
was one of the few places in the country
that didn't really have a mortgage
meltdown uh simply because it's got
State rules that make it very difficult
to buy a house unless you've got 20 down
which seems to me like a fairly
straightforward and intelligent
regulation
yes go ahead the first question
you know I I I I I agree with Kevin that
there's not much for the reason for the
suburbs to get financially committed to
the the problems of Detroit from an
annexation or any other perspective
but I also think it's going to be very
hard for Detroit to ever turn it around
unless Sovereign suburbs become a part
of that because it's it's it's uh you
you have an awful lot of resources
Beyond Financial in the Suburban areas
and they do have a stake in it because
they they their image is a reflection of
the image of Detroit and and so I I well
I I don't think any of them are going to
want to agree with that I agree
completely with what Kevin just said but
I think they also need to be part of the
solution and that to me is a question of
leadership the leader leadership of
Detroit Leadership in Michigan should
should help to Rally that as part of the
effort
I'm from the Detroit area and I'm one of
those suburbs okay
I've been watching the bankruptcy and
I'm somewhat puzzled when the settlement
is working its way through the court and
will be finalized
you sound very disappointed uh in terms
of the percentage of cut that the
pensioners will have to take
realistically if you had your way
how deep with the cuts have to be in
order to make a significant dent
in our debt oh I would cut them to
whatever brought the unfunded
liabilities to zero
so it would be a lot I don't know the
numbers on that but um it would look
like half probably I would assume maybe
more
this is a question for you the panelists
is there a role for 401ks in you know
instead of giving pensions
some some different method of financing
yeah there's there's a uh I think they
called 401a uh in in a public uh entity
in our city had a combined 401a plan for
a lot of the administration in addition
to the defined benefit plans in the like
the rank and file police and fire
I think that um you know one of the
things we really ran into in the in the
middle of the 20th century uh partly
having to do with wage and price
controls uh related to the war was
having this paternalistic relationship
between people and their employers you
know your employer's in charge of your
health care your employer is in charge
of your retirement you know pay your own
damn health care and save for your own
damn retirement and you know your
employer writes you a check every two
weeks and that's that uh it seems like a
much simpler way to do it I mean
certainly in the private sector but
obviously in the public sector where the
accounting is just you know nightmarish
and there's no sense of accountability
yeah I I would look at Corporate America
where
years ago the Divine Benefit Plan was
much more common now there's very few
corporations that would still offer that
so you actually see that in private
sector people have migrated away from
defined benefit toward defined
contribution the the question is how to
do it not if you should
I think there's more for Wayne than
anybody but I'm listening to what's been
said about pensions in chapter nine and
I'm trying to figure this whole thing
out pensions are paid from either
current earnings or current cash flow or
something you've set aside for the
future in a dominant or whatever you
might want to call it if pensions are
exempt from the bankruptcy rules where
does the cash come from when you don't
have the current cash flow and or
whatever you've set aside for the future
doesn't that lead to Ultimate bankruptcy
too yeah and that's part of the
complication when you deal with the
system to simplify it you do have
um an asset right you have the pension
fund that's being managed in California
that's Calpers and there's there's
something like that across the country
and there's the asset and and Rick
referred to that as well that when the
value of that asset changes right then
you have a different payment that the
city has to make but what happens is the
actuaries come up with some number that
says based on the benefits that you're
offering and based on their age profile
and all these statistics you need to
give us this much money now sometimes
the the pensions will say hey I can make
six percent return so you can give them
less yes or they'll say I'll be four and
so there's all those games that can be
played and that kind of gets to the
question in terms of moving to Define
contribution as opposed to defined
benefit
ultimately the cash runs out yes
there's somebody there's somebody else's
problem uh you know look they're going
to spend one out of every five dollars
if they're on the current path they're
going to hit him one out of every five
dollars that comes into the government
in the general fund is going to go to
pay uh pension costs that might be too
far and people won't accept that because
if you only have 80 of your budget to
pay for services right you you need to
pay for your police your firemen ideally
invest in your infrastructure I mean
there's all sorts of other city services
that we're not getting into
that that need to be funded as well and
that gets crowded out so I don't think
it gets to zero it gets there's some
number in between but that's that is the
problem but there's a difference between
what is fiscally possible and what the
courts are saying too
well just to point out in the sense it's
worse than you think because in the case
of Detroit at least they had some years
in which they're pension Investments
outperform their expectations so they
just paid the money out in bonuses they
called it the 13th month check
and uh millions of dollars were taken
out of the pension fund that way we're
going to go one two and then I think
there was a third one in the front Okay
uh about Kevin about Detroit uh and it's
just a comment and you can comment on it
but sometimes if you're in a city
surrounding our suburb is sort of a soap
opera that you watch but it really does
affect us Oakland county is one of the
best run counties in the country and
their uh their rates their bond ratings
went down and when they asked why they
said you're in the neighborhood and so
it does really affect those that are
around them well sure I mean there's
always the question of what are you a
suburb of
you know there's it's one thing to be
Greenwich Connecticut a different thing
to be on the suburbs of Detroit I say
this is a guy who used to work for a
newspaper company that had the great
idea of buying all the Suburban
newspapers around Detroit
which also went into bankruptcy twice so
past is prologue
it's for mayor Baker thank you for your
I'm a part-time Floridian so I am
familiar with your leadership and thank
you you are to be commended my question
is have you ever thought of running for
any higher office
that's my sister out there
[Laughter]
you know I almost made the comment when
I went up there that Wayne's story about
Tiger Woods really his whole speech was
about everybody should move to Florida
um I'll give you a straight answer I uh
finished office in 2010 with my children
were four and five years old when I took
office and and they grew up at City Hall
and I made a decision to get them out of
high school before I ran for another
office
and my daughter is a freshman at college
and my son is a senior
okay
comments about pensions have largely
dwelt on fire and police and that kind
of thing but particularly in the state
of California so Wayne this might be in
your bailiwick the education system is
so extensive public education but also
the community college system and to what
extent do the liabilities pension
liabilities of the education system
affect the the viability of the Cities
the short answer is a lot
um
look at prop 30 I mentioned that the um
California schools in California they
have so much budget rigidity and so many
uh requirements to spend money here and
spend money there but they have across
all their budgets they've been spending
less and less money on education so the
the amount of money that California can
spend on education as a share of its
budget has been going down for a long
time and that's because mandates from
Health Care have been going up so as
Healthcare expenditures have been taking
a larger share they're crowding out all
sorts of spending on on education and
that's going to happen with pensions
that's going to happen with a lot of the
the retiree health benefits so and
that's part of the problem is as these
expenditures that we've kicked down the
road come and those chickens come home
to roost we're not going to be able to
spend the spend the money in the
services that we actually need and
expect so that that actually is the
problem
we're going to take one last final
question in the back there yes
foreign
yeah thank you thank you um I've been
sort of speculating uh well what could
be done I'm thinking partly on public
Choice lines so this might very well be
a question for Wayne to answer
um perhaps
uh some entity I'm not sure whether it
would be California state or maybe even
the federal government might offer a
deal something like we'll help you get
out of your current bankruptcy problems
provided that you adopt some
constitutional rule this would of course
in California require a state
Constitutional Amendment that no entity
can obligate future governments in their
spending that is to say that any public
any pensions have to be fully funded
immediately and maybe on that basis that
deal could be made to help help some
cities or whatever out of bankruptcy
outcomes
uh I I wrote a book with Arthur Laffer
on California called Eureka and that's
exactly very similar to that is what we
argued is that the budget rules are so
bad and the tax system is so bad that
you you need fundamental reform and you
need to put those into some sort of
constitutional framework so that you
don't end back up in the situation I
don't pretend though that that is
actually a politically viable and I
think you know if that's the goal we
need to have kind of a stepping stones
towards that because unfortunately
that's not going to get uh implemented
anytime soon
thank you please join me in welcoming
our distinguished panelists
[Applause]
just just a couple of words uh I
something that is very helpful I would
point out